grannie ah no is a small Italian town
south of Naples pasta is made here but
not just any pasta we make the best
pasta in the world
Arturo elefante could be described as
the rising star in the pasta firmament
gourmet is far and wide say he makes the
world's best pasta and pasta featured a
campy his working day starts above the
rooftops of Naples one of the key
ingredients is the weather we ought to
get 30 to 40 percent you mean things
like this are good for the pasta
elefantes recipe for success combines
ideal weather conditions with local
ingredients such as durum wheat from the
next town sun sea water in the mountain
breeze make for ideal growing conditions
the wheat is delivered once a week
Arturo is working on a new variety of
pasta he uses a bronze perforated filter
to achieve the required shape the
machine saves me work so it doesn't take
as much effort that's not how it used to
be when we made the pasta by hand we can
put out several times as much today the
biggest challenge is the dough the sole
ingredients water and durum wheat flour
are blended without air and the dough is
pushed through the filter under high
heat and pressure this is the first time
our Toros made a TK long spiral shaped
pasta italy is the world's largest pasta
producer with more than three million
tons annually
this is elefantes favorite variety even
if different forms are made from the
same dough other factors play a role
each pasta shape can only be eaten with
a specific kind of sauce little pasta
only with broth and we all need
spaghetti with seafood pasta is a
quintessentially Italian specialty but
the oldest surviving pasta recipe came
from China it was written on parchment
nearly 4000 years ago the Greeks and
Romans discovered pasta early on tomb
images dating back to the 4th century BC
depict sacks of flour and rolling pins
[Music]
the Arabs are credited with being the
first to drive fresh noodles so they
would keep this pasta has to dry for
nearly 50 hours before it's packed the
factory turns out some three tons a day
yeah that's me in the picture it's nice
to know my photos are going all around
the world now everybody can see I'm the
one who made this pasta the deciding
moment boss Giuseppe DiMartino puts the
new creation to the taste test only if
he gives it his blessing will it go into
production you've done fabulous work he
specifies perfect color ideal shape
nothing's left on the fork this pasta is
precisely al dente I really do make the
best pasta in the world it's to be sent
to Don Alfonso a Michelin star
restaurant and one of the best in Italy
it's been a family business for over a
hundred years a three-course meal can
cost some 200 euros star chef Ernesto
you kirino's recipe for success is to
use simple high-quality ingredients
already has a wonderful smell of wheat
that's the first thing I notice yeah
this was the junk now let's taste it
his idea is a straightforward dish of
olive oil pepperoncini and tuna will the
pasta make it onto the menu for today
[Music]
the chef says nothing he just quietly
enjoys compliments to the chef and of
course compliments to me it's a hit
Arturo elefantes pasta appears on the
menu of a two-star restaurant from a
small town just outside Naples this
could well be the world's best pasta
[Music]